the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok first a lot of people is outside
today light sweater midterm number one
we will have it at the week after
Wednesday after you come back and that
April force and as the email Jonathan
send out before you will be closed book
but you will allow one sheet as much as
you can cram into it right ok so one
should note and I'm asking Jonathan who
put the previous example of the midterm
online so you can use that as a example
and expect a similar level and I will
cover the first five chapters so
actually essentially by Monday I'll
finish a chapter 5 and so we do have a
homework number 6 also due on that same
day gets to say you need to do homework
to get familiar from with the day a
content of chapter 5 any questions
ok the perb don't worry the purpose is
not to test you it's just a chance to
the second midterm is a open book is
take home so this is a the first chapter
seen in a census
some of you came to me si can pass the
course I I can't guarantee you pass
course but say I think if you really
know the content the first five chapters
you should be able to answer a lot of
questions on the micro nano Corps
qualifying exams the micro nano Corps is
in the four mouthful giving you paper to
read and they come back answer questions
from different angles so that's that's
my my finish you should be able okay so
coming back to the nos lecture we
discussed what's the energy carried by
electromagnetic wave that's a pointing
vector and then we took the plan wave
solution of electromagnetic wave in a
medium and we calculate the pointing
vector and from that we learned that the
energy the pointing vector decays
exponentially iccs dealt determined by
the absorption coefficient which is the
four pi Kappa over lambda I recall for
optical waves lambda is 10 to the minus
fifth right so essentially Kappa could
be very small number 10 to the minus 7
and it's very still very important
because you do 4pi and say 10 to the
minus 7 divided by 10 to the minus 6 you
get a what and that means it's a steel
one ok depends on the lens of course is
exponential our for X right so this X is
a when Delta is the universe Oh equal x
equals Delta y equals humerus of the
Alpha this exponent here is really one
so that Delta is the penetration depth
as I say when they light intensity
decays exponential minus one so that's
the EM wave propagation inside the
medium that's a personal always said and
then we started looking at the
flashing and refraction all for EM wave
at the interface and for that we have to
be careful of the polarization I say for
you know I took a filter if it's
pointing in any direction we can
decompose it into a TEM wave and the TE
way and the plan of incidence dependent
defined based on the wave vector of the
incident at the norm right so if the TM
is a transverse magnetic that's the
electric field is in the plan that's why
the parallel is a this P means parallel
and symbol parallel and TE is a
transverse electric away that's the
electric field a is a perpendicular to
the plan of the incident perpendicular
and SS is probably German for the
perpendicular if anybody knows German
then we have based on the boundary
condition derived from Maxwell equation
we can eventually write down what's the
reflection coefficient with there's no
reflectance because it's a ratio of the
reflect the electrical field is the
field ratio reflashing for coefficient
and transmission coefficient so I'm not
going to repeat this formula but
essentially you can calculate the
reflectance based on reflection
coefficient and transmission coefficient
you can calculate ins and transmittance
for any angle of incident and as long as
you know the refractive index of both
sides of the media and this is of course
assuming perfect interface remember we
have not added I've made a comment of
this way vector conservation right so
this is a specular reflection and that's
what this new law tells us the angle of
incidence equals angle of reflection and
but see I'd like to always if you want
to show your knowledge right and very
useful this is always I see for my
student I say
skill that you should develop over the
graduate years if you haven't developed
you were undergraduate here is where you
walk out you solve over 90% of the
problem in five minutes and so they may
I say it's back of envelope skill
because so somebody gave me material I
say okay that's a refractive index range
and that's what I know roughly what's
the reflection right so this is a
perpendicular incidence right formula
and that's that you don't need to
remember the angular dependent but this
is the one that I keep in my mind when I
do my back of envelope given any surface
okay
and so we use a glass and silicon as a
example so you can see typical
reflections of this matures and we stop
there I want to do more discussion one
we say if we look at the Chanel no the
other incidents that we better vector
conservation right so we got M 1 sine
theta 1 theta I that's a AG of incidence
equals n 2 sine see that he this is the
transmitted right so we have this is the
light comes in and typically air which
is a vacuum yeah for for pretty much of
vacuum depends on the wavelength and the
refractive index is a 1 and then inside
the material typical refractive index is
larger than 1 and so your angle is
bending the reflect a refracting angle
theta T becomes smaller right so this is
snow law but you could have a opposite
case where the light is traveling inside
a medium and go out right and after it
goes to first surface and may go say
inside the media
and so in that case if M 1 so if M 1 is
another 10 - right and you can say my
say refracted angle see that T is larger
than C the eye right so this is my see
that T is larger than C the eye and then
you ensure humor you come to the
situation where this theta T goes 90
degree so how yeah so what happens after
that right so if theta equals 90 degree
you get a 6 I theta I and we say this is
a critical angle equals n2 over n1 and
you can see this ratio is less than 1 so
at this angle above this angle with
theta I is larger than Sita I critical
and you go to charity
see reflectance and transmittance
formula and you'll find that that R
equals 1 so the light is totally
reflected reflectance is a hundred
percent so R equals one and that's a
total reflection at old [ __ ] sometimes
there's a total internal reflection
right so this is a rapid a internal
means for example if you go from inside
a glass into air right the night is
confined in the glass and so it's
interesting you can put in the typical
Amber if this is a air is going from
glass to air right air is one class of
1.5 so 1 dy 1.5 oxide shocked oxide I
think in that case I got a 42 degree so
that's actually a very large angle right
if you have claw
and what it means if this is a 42 so any
light with the incident angle larger
than 42 degree were not the escape of
glass okay so this is the principle of
or optic fibers right so optic fiber has
an inner core and and then say it has an
outer core and this outer core has a
smaller refractive index so during the
glass deposition pulling they change the
composition of the outer layer to make
the outer layer smaller refractive index
so that when you like I'm saying you
will keep bending and the inside okay so
when you use the opto fiber you don't
want to bend a really sharp because that
angle of incidence would be above the
critical angle they lie to were leaked
all right and in fact yesterday I was in
Baltimore having known she was a
somebody who was he see he said they
talked to you know this optic fiber she
was awarded Nobel Prize a few years back
right this is very simple idea and he
said he because I was having lunch with
somebody from Corning so we're talking
glass and this guy was saying that he
the he asked Kelly yeah calling in
winter about the idea at the time it was
a proposed he was proposing using this
for the communication application right
and how people reacted and people were
just to say that's crazy
are you thinking about glass because
before that I everybody use the
communication is the electrical wires
right going from wire electrical wire to
glass you can say the some of the human
very simple idea actually gets very hard
to be accepted this internal reflection
is a really
for physics right right and but there
are a lot of elite ideas and a lot of
application and if your engineer it's
simpler is better and then I can share
feel right say if you think about I said
classes 1.5 if you do silicon what a
silicon is three point five one over
three point five oxide give you sixteen
sixteen I have here I have sixteen point
six degree so which means right silicon
all the light above sixteen degree
coming to the surface doesn't go out
right so this is where people use this
idea to do light trapping in silicon
right we said silicon in the indirect
gap semiconductor is not good at
absorption and so if you somehow if you
think about this okay I have surface
here
I got a roughness coming in the light
comes in here but they reflected over
angle into here and I did other surfaces
it's totally internally reflected it
will come back right so you have Travis
the longer distance and bunch more times
and that's how you can reduce the
thickness and yet still achieve higher
absorption right nitride and this is a
still a very active field of research
this is a geometric optics that were
just talking about trajectory of light
didn't consider the face about how to
actually achieve maximum light happen
with the smallest material is we have
for example de project trying to make
semia solar cell but they still sitcom
based but still achieve high efficiency
and let me give you another there are
many many example using this I remember
I D peak so for the see optics say the
photonics if you're safe you probably
around ten years ago there was a big
bubble like housing bubble
not as large but say the stalker when
the roof lot of optics communication
company got very rich right and one
because that's the Internet and after
that is the Internet so one of the
challenge is how you switch light the
Russians right and there was this lead I
dear doing man switching micro switching
right so this idea would say basically
you have a channel right and you have
like something is typically totally
internally reflected so it doesn't go
through and then next time and you push
a liquid that has the same refractive
index as a glass or very close right in
that case you have all the index matched
and doesn't have a total internal
reflection anymore so it just go through
right it's a very simple idea and I
think that was from HP I don't think
they were successful commercializing it
but the study and in fact every all the
leaders use this effect so not all but
most of lasers
so the solid-state laser what it has is
a common well very single Mouse night
right and this is a quantum world where
electrons and holes recombine and give
up a photon right and that sickness of
that well is about a hundred unstrung or
a sinner but the light wavelength is a
much larger right so what it has is
another there is another cladding
optical layer so this is this is the
charge and the electron my gradual wave
goes this way and the refractive index
of the surrounding layer is smaller so
the light is forced to bounce along the
layer direction so this effects vitally
used in many
any devices very simple and it's a total
internal reflection okay but what's
there is even something more interesting
and that is you can say that when theta
I is larger than theta say cry say about
critical angle the reflectance is 1 but
at t right the transmission coefficient
is not 1 at 0 and in fact you can go to
check the transmission coefficient for
we derived is 2 + 1 + cosine theta I and
+ 2 cosine theta I plus everyone sine
cosine see that he okay
cosine see that he I didn't see
mathematically I didn't say the one is
zero right because we have we've Sita I
is larger than critical angle of
incidence that means I can still use
yellow sine theta I mathematically
that's a solution of Maxwell equation
didn't see Maxwell equation didn't
exclude it right so see how I if you go
to do this you'll see is larger than one
st. in Hawaii right and now sine theta T
the angle of you transmit it right it's
imaginary you go sign that's the imagine
number and the cosine theta T equals a 1
mass of sine see that he is square and
this larger than Y so this is the magic
number right so let's say is the I times
B so I substitute this one into the back
into the transmission coefficient it's
not zero right
and I look under the field on the other
side so if you look like the transmitter
the field of course is a proportional to
transmission coefficient and the
incident field I have maybe the angular
is not quite right so maybe right it is
just in the proportional and then I have
my exponential factor the phase factor
minus I Omega t minus n 2 X sine see
that T plus + 2 Z cosine see that he
over C 0 so that's my this is not 0 this
is the incident right my electric field
on the other side is not 0 okay and what
happens is cosine C that is the
imaginary when cosine C that is the
imaginary I have a magical number here I
have not a imaginal number here it gives
me a real number right and that real
number is exponentially decay so my
electric field on the other side is the
exponential decay function and this is
the evil action wave so when my angle
and one is n 2 and angle incidence the
larger than critical angle right the
electric field on the other side
exponential decay from the surface and
the real part the the X component if you
look at n 2 sine theta equals n 1 sine
theta I so that's actually real right so
this wave whether what you have is a
wave propagating in the X direction on
the surface and decays exponentially on
the other side right and this is the
evil a sine wave
okay and but you see how is that
possible you have a field the
transmission is not it zero right so
what it happens is you go to calculate
although the T is itself is not zero but
at how they transmitted energy zero the
average Poynting vector is zero so they
feel the comes in goes out back so the
average speak and there's a net non lead
energy go from one side to the other
that's what they give a lesson weight
and recall in the case of discussing
electrons
that's how proud I say a situation right
we say okay your energy of the electron
comes in goes say if the energy is less
then the barrier height your wave
function on this side is not zero right
but you got calculated the material flux
the particle flux is there on the other
side that's the even less and field for
mature way so all waves have this car is
ticks okay
and how how fast it decay you go to
check here is essentially if you say
Omega or T C zero and the seed hard
device is of the order of women's so
that decay is of the order wavelength
and we said okay for material wave the
wavelengths maybe is a few angstroms
right last time we say people use that
to do the IBM interview example I told
you finish get a scanning tunneling
microscope let's use the evil as some
way for mature way electrons here
you gotta even lessen wave on the other
side and there are a lot of us a
different application I'll discuss more
later on okay
so this is the Claire law and IVA lesson
way and let me also make one more
comment because here all our derivation
is assumed and one and two C are real
and if n 2 is complex okay and ago you
go to check of your equation derivation
process no problem everything still is
applicable it's mathematically a
solution of the Maxwell equation so what
it means is when you look at your Chanel
law and one sine theta-1
I let me assume my is real first okay
and yogurt you go together say n2 is
complex society that he is complex
enough right so science is that he is
complex is a plus bi and cosine see that
he you do to your operation C plus D I
so both are complex I mean it's the same
formula you do your complex number
operation okay but when both are complex
you go to look either your R wave here
right sciency that is complex cosine say
that he okay in fact here will be real
but say what you'll find out is that
this wave inside in the when propagating
into a medium the constant amplitude is
actually in the Z direction the constant
amplitude surface right the amplitude
that's when Z each Z equal constant that
field account is K is a constant
amplitude but constant phase is going in
the other direction so the constant
phase constant amplitude actually do not
coincide and this is an income genius
way
but say all the formula we gave still
applicable so there's no problem as long
as you do your complex lumber operation
consistently and I remember say the node
is I only know for sure so you have to
very be very careful declare your
complex numbers otherwise that you run
into problems ah one more what about my
is also complex right and one is also
complex and this is a point that
probably most people don't know
everything still applicable so most
people know that okay but if you do your
operation you find that R plus tau 2 not
equal to 1 okay and at the surface
there's an absorption so I actually I
run what I I found this other when I was
a graduate student doing all the math
and so what's happen in there
I wouldn't go when I say I went to ask
her my professor say that's strange ok
so I went to check a lot of books I
thought I could write a paper I turns
out I was only a hundred years late
right I was it was mocks boring in fact
that they discuss all those issues max
born as a say they they born get I say
or not but say it's a it's all in there
so before okay so this is all the
discussion that I didn't finish and so
we now know at least say how to
calculate the reflection of electron at
the interface we gave a lot more
incidence I said that you should be able
to do and
we did say like for magnetic wave at the
interface and the next one is acoustical
wave right so all those waves are
similar but the equations are different
why is the shorter equation here is a
Maxwell equation so let me briefly talk
about acoustic wave this isn't my last
because I go from simpler to more
complicated but your waving in fact the
Schrodinger equation there is a scalar
right Maxwell equation is a transverse
wave to component and you learn the
photons acoustic wave has three
components longitudinal where two
transverse waves so your equation will
be a lot more complex and in the
continuum limit right in continuum limit
you can write a set of a differential
equation for crystal wave propagation in
the media and the way to derive that
equation is say starting from F equals
MA right there are not many questions
and so the F equals MA and then we need
to say inside the material how I can
convert this into the atomic
displacement because acoustic wave
essentially they Adams the mature
displacement from equilibrium position
right so if you say okay displacement is
the R - R 0 that's the equilibrium
position then a is just so the
derivative right second order derivative
so now you can try to say how you can
relate both sides so that you get a 1
equation
one question for displacement or
velocity of the material wave and the
way you do it is think about the force
is related to stress in the material
right and stress is related to strength
strain is related to displacement so if
you write all those relation you uni
merely get a wave equation for the
displacement and that's the ku steel
wave equation okay just a few more on
that and what you have here is the
string tip curved away
alright and strip I'm not going to write
the old equation so string is say a
tensor and it's defined as a DUI the XJ
plus DOJ DXi okay and that's the
strength and stress tensor okay so we
have what's the the Hookes law in the
material in the complicated form the the
most say general form is really a tensor
I say they force the stress is related
to the strain right is related to the
strength s so this a two hat means the
second order tensor okay and that
coefficient right is the stiffness
mature stiffness elastic stiffness
constant and this one is something times
tensor I say is actually to get a second
order tensor from a second order tensor
multiplication this should be a fourth
order tensor okay so this is real
the fourth order tensor and each order
is the three component vector its three
component second alternate online
component fourth order tensor is
eighty-one component okay so anybody do
make a solid mechanics that's you must
be very good in the math okay that's a
lot of food see it's a tensor operation
and in the case for in fact that you can
do to symmetry you can simplify 81 to 36
and if you get an isotropic material you
got only two so that's the different
assumptions me but essentially so you
have displacement you have your stress
and your force right generally if you
have a surface you have a norm you have
stress tensor here Sigma right you have
n it's norm then they say is the stress
tensor I'll say the norm times a stress
tensor that gives you the force acting
on that surface
right so essentially here those relation
gave me if I substitute everything back
into the F equals MA I should get
acoustic wave equation in the material
but say except here if you I was looking
at this huh huh I should I know this one
I get a time or second order time
derivative right on the left hand side I
should get the space second-order
derivative to get a wave equation right
so the way I just wrote the FE equation
Sigma will give a Sigma equals a
proposer 2's that's only in first-order
in space it's not second order in space
yeah and the reason is you have to do it
your valid element analysis so you take
a differential volume right you have
force difference right that's the left
force that difference will give you this
space second order derivative and so you
gotta say second order
on the left hand side second order time
derivative in the right hand side you
get a wave equation that's acoustic wave
equation you can say if I write it down
it will be very very long okay so this
is a in general you can have the
equation for Christie wave and if you
can also calculate there is a also
acoustic pointing vector that's the
energy okay the time average of the
acoustic pointing Wagga this is neither
the strength pony vector is one half
real part of velocity which is the first
order derivative and that times this
stress tensor so this is a like the
force times of velocity gives you the
world yesterday cuz the energy flux
there okay and now what happens for
acoustic wave coming towards the
interface okay
and when we have electromagnetic wave we
have of course reflection and refraction
and that's the same we have but it
depends on whether the incoming wave is
the longitudinal wave it's a transverse
wave and if it's a transverse wave which
the russian i project right the plan of
the incident and so if the displacement
is in decline for instance that's an S
wave wave and here longitudinal wave
this is the l word right and in most
general case what happens is you do your
again you are at the interface you have
boundary condition and you can derive
and turns out in general case s wave a
will a lunch
kingside three ways you can have also
longitudinal where you can have SOA web
and sh-sh is the other polarization
perpendicular to the plan incidence so
that's the complication for coastal
waves and you have a mode conversion
okay from one mode one polarization to
other polarization and if because of
this you can also have transmitted also
have three polarizations okay and if
it's an isotropic media you only have a
two branch right so this will be
degenerate and you can have L waves and
see the transverse wave so this is the
general case and the formula in fact
there was a really good book when that's
a book by old I would suggest if anybody
interesting those because they actually
trade Maxwell equation and the coos will
wave equation is side by side and that
gives us a very good learning and then
when I read our question waves so that's
the I know a Maxwell equation that's how
I learn acoustic wave okay
and now if you go to do I'm not going to
give you any angular relation by the
reflectance of crystal wave right at the
lower incidence it's very similar to the
reflectance of Optio wave eleméry
incidents and same as the electron waves
a lot more incidents so reflectance is Z
1 minus Z 2 Z 1 plus Z 2 square well
this is they is the density times
velocity square root and this is
acoustic impedance
okay so it's a density times velocity
speed of sound they can roughly think
that and again it's the difference in
acoustic impedance that gives the
reflashing
of acoustic waves right and you can
write your Chanel law and for example
your the the problem is the for Chanel
law this is a way ionger
IC velocity of the incident wave but say
even on the same side you can have
reflection to other angle different mode
conversion right the lateral momentum so
KX has to conserve that's a yellow and
so what you have is even for the same
side right let's say reflected also for
lunch children let's say you then you
have to say the largest shooting wave
there's the angle their angular relation
that's essentially tells you the lateral
movement kumkum the ways you and
therefore the other side you have
similar right if it's transmitted we T
transmitted yeah say on they say let's
reflect either side transmit aside so
those are the corresponding our laws for
Christy waves so again you can have the
if you look at those relations you can
still have total internal reflection
acoustic wave can also be totally
internally reflected so if you go from
medium like say I think it's germane you
for example to silicon if you launch C
largest waves and you look at the
relation there is a total critical angle
and above the critical angle they'll
reflect total internal reflection
and along the other side that you have
correspondingly evil Essen way doesn't
carry energy to the other side but the
Tama go there is vibration exponent or
decay from the surface okay so all those
wave have similar phenomena you see the
equations your starways could be very
different but general wave behavior
share a lot of similarities okay so
that's waves at a single interface right
and what we moving on there is what
about multiple interfaces and single
interface is the only reflection
refraction I want to I don't want to
before I reach this I do want to make
another comment we said that okay
because this is snail already for any of
the ligand here you you draw your light
how the reflection refraction should
happen then if anything here it goes
this way you'll see your seat ha R goes
to the other way so the that's why the
beginning there a lot of loose articles
over light been wrong way or stuff when
electromagnetic metamaterials
okay so whatever protein next is
multi-layer stem films
in thin films so when I say that before
we have why interface and now let's go
to to interface right that's a goal from
to interface before it to a interface
actually cost 3/4 and so the physics
what happens is I have the wave comes in
the first interface and I say m 1 & 2 &
3 my formula is written in terms of a
small end but you can write a capital m
everything is identical okay and so what
happens is at the first interface you
have refraction you have reflection you
can use your friend nail formula to
calculate every flashing and refraction
transmit it and when it comes to the
second you propagate right we know how
to ride the wave propagation the phase
factor here we have the phase factor
right that's my face factor so when
they's a change I know how to write it
down for different media and then I the
second interface you have reflashing you
have transmission and once you're
transmitting and 3 I don't have anything
coming back so I can say that part is
going forward this one coming back it's
a troublesome because they come back and
here the interface again and then I got
again transmission from 2 to 1 and
reflection every time I can use my
friend nail formula plus the propagating
face factor to twist right so
transmission reflection and that's one
way to do it you add up what they feel
that you use different nail formula but
it's pretty tedious I can see you can
see it's an infinite series because of
their infinite number of reflashing
transmission in theory right so that's a
you twist they feel and if you don't
consider the face of the light right
um way then that's people do this is a
pretty much like among hollow people do
retrace them they trace the trajectory
of light bundles and their commercial
code to do that in complicated geometry
but when you have those face also
changing it becomes a lot more
complicated to actually trace and carry
your face of the field and not very
computationally efficient so at least
the four thin films
flat structure there are different way
other other ways to do it and the next
way is here at each interface I can use
the friend alright
formula but see the last one is I don't
care about the city I add this all
together because of the face factor is
safe which one right so okay I say this
is my incident this is a total resulted
with flashing right and this is my total
forward propagated and my reflected
propagating inside the film and this is
my total transmitted right and in that
case I I do not know the relationship
between this point at this point because
this one is summing up of many of this
forward same this is a summing up of
many backward right so I have to use my
boundary condition to refine the
relations amount if incident reflected
here is forward backward transmitted so
this is another way to do it using
boundary condition right and this is a
resultant wave let's say positive this
is the back or propagated reflected and
you say then and you of course there are
different polarization if I considered
here and waved and that's what I have to
do as we do a singer plan and here is
transmitted right so that's a that's a
way that I'm going to follow through
some math and you in this way this way
is a pretty intuitive mathematically but
even this way is not a very convenient
if you have many layers and they if you
have many mayors the beste is using a
matrix format and the matrix format is
not to say I consider total electric
field this is incident reflected right
but I don't distinguish incident
reflected the total local electric field
and the total magnetic field so here I
have
and the the the point I want to use is
the continuity right if I if you record
a boundary condition for a year wave is
at the interface I have the tangential
component of electric field and magnetic
field as long as there's no sheet car in
there is equal on both sides so so what
I'm going to do is say I used to say I
know the phase factor from this point at
this point and from this point at this
point so I know actually the relation
the phase be the relation between the
electrical and magnetic field between
these two points and these two points
will be reflected eyes let's say I have
a x0 h y0 that's the at this point
relate to this point through a matrix
and that matrix that you can get us from
the solution of Maxwell's equation and
then to this point is e X let's say here
I have D this is thickness and H Y D so
this matrix will make me my life much
easier because if I know they so you
relate the electric field total it's not
forward backward is add up or forward
and backward total electric field
through the magnetic field at this point
through the total electric field total
magnetic field through a matrix element
and then now my continuity is a
propagating to the other side this
electric field magnetic field is the
same on both sides so this point is the
same as this point so I can connect and
many many layers together just by matrix
some may say multiplications continue
this
to build up any layer so this one is a
most convenient to use and that's
transfer matrix and in fact the transfer
matrix is used widely for many different
problems there are people dealing with
multi layer heat conduction right and in
that case your continuity is the
temperature and heat flux at the
interface that continues
so using that if you can relate the
temperature and heat flux at this point
to this point and across the interface
continues so you just to see write a
similar matrix and you do your matrix
multiplication for many layers right so
it's a very useful mathematical approach
for many different problems if I say
what I'm going to do is spend a little
bit of time here and let's use this
together the basic idea how I'm going to
do multi layers and you what do we need
to write down is essentially like a two
interface condition before last lecture
we wrote why interface will have two
equations and now I have two interface
and I need to write the propagating they
face and it'll carry because from this
point to this point there's a distance
traveled and if I look at this right
plan wave when cosy is a moment right
Omega doesn't is the same and the X
component that's what they say is this
real or take care so this one I don't
ask I don't need to vary it Austria law
is always a valid and Omega T I don't
need to vary what I need to wear is
carrying this phase term the Z
because I go from this is my Z Direction
right when I go from this point to this
point I have if this is origin zero to D
that's my Z okay so what I have you can
rather your Eid the incident and
exponential must I the face factor you
know I write Z directions and to know C
N 1 and 1 cosine theta I and lambda Z so
this is my incident and similarly
reflected so you have to be comfortable
in carrying this a positive and one
cosine theta I plus because of Chanel
law so theta the angular is the same Z
right so this is the incident reflected
in medium 1 and same you can write they
transmit it right
the for property plus like I said that I
do not this is not just of this the
original not just from AI from the motor
reflection so I don't know the relation
so I want to say this is the e they say
plus exponential phase factor inside is
I + 2 cosine Z had let's say here using
2 and lambda Z and E minus exponential
that is opposite the ration and 2 cosine
theta 2 lambda Z
right you can also write the
transmission there now I apply the
continuity the same boundary condition
as I did before for the first interface
and for the second interface the
tangential component of the electric and
the magnetic field continues right so
for the first interface when I take my
origin of z equals zero
cleverly choosing your coordinate okay
so that is the tangential component so e
I times cosine theta plus e R cosine
theta R equals y plus cosine theta two
plus e months cosine see that hoop right
so that's the tangential component the
two sides this side and this side
remember I always add up the total I
didn't say is the incident or is it the
total electric field yes
yeah I'm sorry so this one is the same
said I see the R is the same did I so
there's no law right and and then see
the magnetic field is n remember say is
M one mule cz row and E I - e ER right
that's the relation we say hy we derive
last time the relation if I know you
like to feel that now the magnetic field
is n you say times e that we feel for
opposite propagating because of the the
ration change my right hand rule I have
a negative sign in the front right and
the same is unto mules is 0 E Plus and
mass emails so this is the amplitude he
pricey months of the for propagating and
backward propagating waves and of course
I need a 2 other equation because I have
a plus in my son on ER mana and also
transmitted on now I need a form or two
more equation to close this that's I the
other interface to interface each
interface
give me two equations right so
the other interface now you have to
carry your face factor because when the
way propagating from zero to D so you
have to write Z equals D now again your
electric field the a plus here right
projecting into the X Direction this is
my X direction
it's a cosine theta so it's a cosine see
that tool exponential I Phi minus I Phi
2 Phi 2 is my face factor let's just say
you can look at that is the end tool
because I see that too so let me write
it down so Phi 2 equals n 2 cosine seen
a 2 over lambda times D so emails by I
Phi 2 plus e minus and cosine theta 2 e
I Phi 2 this is a backward going back so
the Z we vector is going backwards so
that's my plus wave plus sign right and
then say my eg transmitted so eg cosine
theta T exponential mass I Phi 3 ok and
this Phi 3 is you do n 3 cosine theta 3
lambda autumn's D it doesn't matter
in fact you can restart your coordinate
this phase factor at the end because
when you calculate the transmitted is uu
this cancer all drops out this face back
when you do the ratio and so I have the
my lattice field is the end to mule c0e
class
nicely - and this is the n stray mule
say zero and et exponential mass I Phi 3
now I have four equations I can solve
for the what I want is really the
reflector to incident that's a
reflectance reflection coefficient
transmit it to incidence that's the
transmission coefficient right so I have
enough equation to solve that problem
and what you find is your R equals the
ER or e I equals R one - that's the
friend L coefficient between one two
interface plus R 2 3 that's a friend L
coefficient Explorer manager - I Phi 2
and divided by 1 plus R 1 to R 2 3
exponential 2 I Phi 2 so this is the
reflection coefficient and similarly you
can do your transmission coefficient the
et the I equals T 1 2 T 2 3 exponential
I Phi 2 and 1 plus R 1 to R 2 3
exponential 2 I Phi 2 so some comments
here so you can see the transmission you
have Wi-Fi - that's the first pass so
doesn't have double there right and the
denominator reflecting that it's always
double so you have a 2 I Phi 2 top of
the back-and-forth right if you look at
this the next transmission is reflashing
come back and go out reflection is the
first one and
then the next one is I have to go for
reflect go by God right so that's where
this factor of two comes from and second
you will see that if you square this
you'll get a sine cosine so you gotta
interference periodical variations of
reflectance and transmittance as a
function of this phase factor so that's
the interference effect okay and I do
want to get a mess down so let me first
give you the mass and then do the
discussion in the next lecture so I have
gone through the resultant wave matter
and really say splitter the electric
field in the forward and backward but I
said that if I do this it's still not
very convenient and the best days to do
this transfer matrix and using the fact
that the both electric and magnetic
field that continues at the interface so
what I needed is to write the here I'm
going to ask you to read more detail in
the book and if I do I want to gather
the transfer matrix but eventually I
have also come back to what I care is
the ratio so write say I care about
reflected the electric field divided by
incident so I have I said what I do in
math is the total total electric field
is a continuous total my gratifies
continues but at the end I really want
to still have to separate them for
incident and reflection so I need a
matrix to relate that and so if you do
your palet let's say your electric field
so this is a either zero right this is
my z and this is my X
and let's say this is a one this is a
tool and so one X component 0 is e IX +
e RX + H 1 Y at 0 so I'm considering a
TM wave so H 1 Y is n 1 mill C 0 and the
e I my CER
you can see now I have relation between
yeses and reflected electric field to
total incident electric field total
incident magnetic field right I can
emerge this and so I write it into
matrix so this one essentially what it
because I want to write everything into
matrix H 0 H 1 1 and here is 0 and this
is the 1 1 1 over P 1 minus 1 over P 1
and e IX e RX so I have a this P 1 is
the surface impedance so the x hy and
for the TM wave we have this cosine
theta + n mu C 0 so this is the 14mm way
and TE way you can write a different
expression right so what I wrote down
here is the total electric field total
magnetic field relate to incident
reflected electric field through matrix
right
so there that's either the first side
because you actually I want to find the
e ie our relation not just the edge is
relation but say what I am using is e
and the H is continues so-yeon H so yi 1
x0 e 1 y 0 to the equal e to X 0 H H 2 y
0 so that's the continuity of tangential
component right so the second is my if
you do your if you go to back to the one
we just written down on the electric
field and relate to magnetic field and
you'll find out is H 2 no e 2 X 0 and
the H 2 y 0 so I want to relate this
point to this point that's in the same
media that's just a phase factor right
so if I redo that relation that gave me
matrix so this point is relate to the
other point what I want is e 2 x @a d h
2y i the d so this is this point here
here that's two points right and in
between is this matrix I want and that's
cosine Phi 2 a minus I P 2 sine Phi 2
and mass I P 2 sine Phi 2 and the cosine
Phi 2 so this is my M transfer matrix
that's what I was saying here
okay and the beauty of this is I relate
this point to this point now if I add
another layer layer straight between
here and here is continuous right so
this point is also this point now to
find this point I time I M the other M
here if this is M 1 this is M 2 a time
another M I will relate to this point
okay so with the transfer matrix this is
my M I see if I have n layers just m1
times m2 times M and so I can do any
layers easily ok and finally is my
transmitted the last one right cool
wink goes out does not have anything
coming back so I still need to relate to
that so my final relation yes
let's say if this is transmitted exd hyd
so and a equals 1 1 over P 3 e TX
because in this case this is my 1 2 3
and the transmitted field only has one
prof for propagating no backward so I
have a simple with this if you can say I
can use all those relation the first one
because this one is continuously equal
this one so I have you can say this
matrix 1 1 let me let me don't do this I
will use this one as my
this is my here is my a let's say this
is a a this is a matrix right so if I
use my continuity is the a times e I X H
R X that's here the equals here this
equals this that's equal to this so
equals M times this one that's at either
the other interface that equals this so
1 1 P 3 and E TX so with this I can
relate the transmitted to incident
reflected 3 incident so this is the no
matter how many layers I just add and
the multiplication of this matrix okay
and the when you do if you do this kind
of calculation this is the people design
any coatings the design coding they'll
do for as lysosome film coating you do
your transfer matrix and they have
various kind of interference effects and
coming to these are the desirable value
and we do those kind of operation decay
is you have to be careful because
sometimes this blew up okay and the
depends on whether you're for example if
your fire itself is complex that's
actually exponential function so this
could create that Cowboys I think I say
for this one what I want to I just want
to stop here I let me not showing the
they I thought I was going to have some
time to browse but say what I want to
say is
if you have not lost you first five
chapters you can now open any journal
you can make a say probably half of the
paper collection - what you learn and I
challenge you to look at the West in any
journal like I say don't consider the
biosigns okay I haven't talked about
that right you were probably I was
looking at the Nano Letters energy
murder science nature photonics laser
matures this morning I think I say I
just don't have time to go through all
this with you but you should be able to
say there something that you can relate
to okay any questions today is beautiful
so I'll finish earlier